there's a picture going viral of Donald
Trump on the campaign Trail signing a
woman's chest just I say chest because
it's high up enough that I don't it's
not totally untoward Trump also clearly
has very very strong autographed
discipline because even as he's signing
this woman's chest his hand is not
touching his hand is you can see a
shadow on the lady's white tank top and
she's smiling she's so excited people
all around him in this bar
like they're meeting a celebrity which
they are and I mentioned the photo
to to return to an objection that some
Republicans are making anti-trump
Republicans are making which is they'll
say yeah Trump's a celebrity but people
shouldn't care about celebrities this
election should not come down to
personality and charm and Charisma and
celebrity damn it that's not what this
election should be about to which I
respond
have you ever seen an election